I'm gonna move that one to that rod
holder there too might as well just have
it there oh we're down here in Chatham
we've got a bunch of boats with us we
have TJ from Hot Tuna we got Jack on
time flies Paul and wicked pissa so
there's a bunch of us down here
hopefully we can all work together and
find the life we're very thankful
there's a lot of boats to work with the
key to catching fish in Chatham is
sharing information so the more boats
the more Eyes On The Water the better
got about six or seven fish on the
screen right now
200 up to 150.
oh Mama are you traveling or are you are
you fishing we're fishing
are you right where you stand or uh 7 11
8 15. I'll head down that way
all right now we got a big wolf pack
stacked up on the bottom from 200 up to
150.
Market sand deals so we'll see what
happens here
Bobby just let Bob know what we're
seeing here so hopefully we can both get
them that's the best case scenario we're
ready for battle
let's just set one up here
all right I'm ready when you are we're
on the spot here already marking we're
just deploying our first two baits so
we're hoping to get a nice quick bite
here but we'll see hopefully it works
out for both of us today oh look at this
oh my God
yep
fat tuna hooked up
go get em bub
right where it started it's crazy all
right I hope yep
Here We Go Again first bait out less
than 20 minutes
a little bit of a weird bite here see
that gun hooked again or a short we're
definitely hooked up to a tune-up it's
acting kind of funny it doesn't want to
take any big runs isn't taking a lot of
drag so we'll play it out here and see
what happens another gut hooked fish
some bottom Johnny
Markham right there
okay
as it is down in Chatham a lot of times
they grab this bait off the bottom and
they bring it up and while they're doing
that
they're not tight so they gut hook it so
he's another gut hooked fish just like
the other day
the biggest thing you worry about with a
gut hook fish is the line chafing
because the hook is all the way down the
fish's throat every time it moves it's
sharp teeth the rubbing against the line
so we need to do whatever we can to get
this fish in quickly before the line
snaps
swivel here let me hop in it don't go
for it big guy
yup yup coming in hot
he's gonna circle around here
come on
right there right there right there
right there
shot buddy
he looked like a good one he's a real
good one Bob he's a real good one
what what what what what
it's not in them it's not in them what
the
Harpoon stopped just brought it back the
tip's still on the pole
we thought we hit that fish we didn't
hit that fish pissed them off yeah I'll
tell you what it almost looks like we
hit a hard spot on that fish probably a
gill plate I thought for sure that thing
was in them never celebrate too early
he's a bit gassed you're gonna get
another shot here
you got him no it's not no it's not get
the Gap get the other get the other half
moon hit him again hit him again hit him
again uh he's good
wrapped up
first bait 20 minutes on the fish that's
why we come down here
good job Bob very good pretty work on
the fish Bob nice work bubble
just kind of landed on him with the help
from you guys thank you
all right
let's get a measurement on this thing
92 baby yeah we'll take that nice every
time we come down here that's why we
come down here
[Music]
working together that's what it's all
about
[Music]